el mismo día en que las miradas estaban
en back but esa ciudad del donbass donde
todas las previsiones de los analistas
dicen que viene en la batalla toda la
fuerza del ejército ruso después de que
tomen el control de cibeles una ciudad
que está totalmente en medio del fuego
para cook fue atacada en la tarde con
diferentes misiles y con también con
artillería fue en varios edificios este
que está a mis espaldas es la escuela de
arte de la biblioteca que se enseña
música aquí se enseña ballet ellos nos
dicen que un proyectil que cayó en la
calle rompió los vidrios de todas estas
edificaciones alrededor pero no fue la
única también cayó otro en uno de los
hospitales de la ciudad otro cerca de
una vivienda residencial donde pudimos
ver a una mujer herida que le estaban
haciendo un torniquete para salvarle su
pierna y también en otras zonas más
alejadas del centro de la ciudad